[Music]
hey
we're back again yeah trying to recover
from that [ __ ] last night
i feel okay yeah
[Laughter]
like i said taking three aspirin right
before you go to bed and drinking a
bunch of water
that's weird it really does it really
does work i woke up at like three
o'clock in the morning
you know what's weird i don't think i
woke up one time because i had to go to
the bathroom but like
i don't think i woke up and then i
didn't wake up again until eight
something i woke up felt
[ __ ] felt rested it was like three
o'clock in the morning the cat was
[ __ ] with me
well yeah i was just going like man why
am i up so early
i finally went back to sleep though
probably around four
and then you slept like yeah but it's
just a weird there's a weird way of
doing it yeah i don't know why i did it
that way
well you know you gotta just as long as
you get your hours in there i couldn't i
was laying awake for a long time because
pookie decided she was gonna sleep she
curls up like right next to
my hip yeah and then so it's i can't
really
i feel bad about moving her you know
because she looks so comfortable
yeah okay the night stalker series
on netflix on netflix it was good i yeah
i actually really and
you know i know enjoy is kind of a weird
word to use so it's four episodes
and the episodes are what like 45 50
minutes each
yeah um you could you can binge watch
them and yeah
go through them yeah we watched them
just all in one sitting it's an easy
binge watch
because it kept you in kept us in there
those must been what
six hours of it yeah well no because i
think it's only
it's i think it's only maybe four hours
was it or maybe a little bit less
seemed to go by fast it did and i really
have to say
much like the um the more recent one the
recent one they did on the yorkshire
ripper
i like that they kind of shift focus a
little bit
and they don't i mean they don't talk
about ramirez
as a person as much
they kind of focus more on
the victims the cops you know
the media that was covering it like what
was going on in the culture like the
whole
cultural kind of context of it and i
think they
they did that with the yorkshire ripper
one too and i kind of like that because
i feel like you know a lot of true crime
series and i love watching a lot of true
crime [ __ ] and you know and i can't
really
criticize too much because i you know i
i read a lot about serial killers and
find them fascinating and stuff but i do
kind of feel like a lot of things
you know you're kind of in danger of
glorifying the serial killer going look
he's you know look how cool and badass
this dude is
so i kind of like that this didn't
really do that um it really
they didn't even like say the name until
the end of the like i think the third
episode like where because it was so it
was very very focused on
you know it it kind of went in real time
sort of like
you know in the timeline of how they did
the investigation how they found out the
[ __ ] and everything like that
so i feel like i mean it was mostly they
talked to frank salerno
who was one of the investigators on it
who also um because i'm sure we've
mentioned him before because he's
quite famous in true crime circles
because he
did the hillside strangler case like you
know a few years before this
and so he was kind of the old grizzled
cop
you know when the richard ramirez [ __ ]
started happening and then you got this
other
guy um gil carrillo and he was kind of
at that time he was kind of like the
young upstart detective
and they teamed up together and
they were pretty much the first ones to
realize that this was a serial killer
because
i mean we did a show about richard
ramirez if you don't know
richard ramirez is one of the very very
very few
serial killers i'm sure there's a couple
other ones out there but not very many
that didn't really have a victim profile
he didn't have a particular way that he
liked killing him he just kept changing
it up
what was the guy's name gorilla yeah
carrillo carrillo yeah
korea was a young uh chicano guy from
like in southern california
yeah and um he was he was kind of new to
all this [ __ ]
and he was the first one to kind of
he had a good hunch he came forward he
says
they were having these child abductions
where they were these children were
getting raped
girls and and boys yes girls i think
yeah
and then he was letting them go and then
they were finding houses burglarized
with people raped tortured killed in it
and uh korea was like this is the same
dude and
and all the other detectives laughed him
off except that one
except like frank salary frank salerno
he was like i think he might be right
about
frank salerno approached him [ __ ] at
the bar
you know they were drinking and eating
and he was just like i want you to work
with me and [ __ ] you know
[ __ ] yes they hooked up and turned
out yeah that dude was right all along
his instincts were right that was the
same dude
they kept finding the same footprints
that same shoe
yeah i think that was kind of the main
thing that linked all the crimes because
other than that they never found any
um other evidence they never found any
fingerprints they never found anything
like that and
as i said the dude seemed i mean he just
would
attack people randomly he didn't give a
[ __ ] if it was like old people
kids men women he didn't give us an
opportunist yeah he was just like
whoever's [ __ ]
sliding glass door was unlocked or
whoever had a window kind of open or
something like that
i don't think he even stalked anybody or
anything i think he just kind of went
around and
you know opportune and you know he would
even do [ __ ] like and they had this one
woman on there that when she was six
years old
um richard ramirez kidnapped her
and put her in like a [ __ ] gym bag or
something like that
and took her to his house presumably and
just raped her over and over and did all
kind of horrible [ __ ] to her yeah
and then just let her go like left her
at a gas station hey go call the cops or
go call your parents or something yeah
he let a lot of them go if he abducted
him
but um it was it you know
the way the story is told it's pretty
good carino carino was like uh
they'd see that footprint at the scene
that shoe print he'd point at it like
that and flicking his partner look at it
and there
said their hair would [ __ ] stand up
like i can
imagine what they'd feel like yeah
there's that they kept seeing that and
they were keeping that
tight under wraps they didn't want
anybody to know
that they were yeah because they didn't
want him to change his shoes you're
right
and that eventually did leak out that
they had his footprint what didn't it
didn't somebody sit
no no he leaked out about the writing on
the walls
no the the thing about the shoes did
leak out
and then what ended up happening was
that somebody
i mean somebody in the police i guess it
wasn't one of them i don't think
told the media for whatever reason and
then the media well no they
they were going they're like we're gonna
go public with it and the cops were like
um hey can you not do that because
he'll change his shoes he'll change his
chains of shoes and then it'll be harder
for us to kind of like figure out which
ones he did or not
so i think they they didn't actually
break it because they said oh well
we're gonna print it but you know if you
guys give us an exclusive interview or
something then we won't print that
right it just seems like all you should
have to do is just say hey can you not
print that because
you know we need that piece of
information for our investigation and we
don't want him
being tipped off because ramirez was
obviously watching the news and like
following the [ __ ]
yeah but he [ __ ] reporters man well
the ones on here were real [ __ ] i
have to say
i mean that's like they didn't really it
seemed like they didn't really care it's
all they cared about was like the story
and then they'll handle it
an investigation and get people killed
just for a story
we know the deal there should be laws
against that
where if they give out information that
they they should get punished for it
if if it hinders an investigation yeah
because i mean there's a reason
yes the public has a right to know to an
extent but there's a reason why
yeah there's a reason why they keep
details like that under
wraps you know for that exact reason
well they get swarmed with copycats too
yeah based on the details some of the
details they give out of fakes so they
can tell
the kids apart so and so you know
because some people some weirdos like to
confess to crimes yeah that they did
falsely and like if you just come
with the details that were in the media
that that was fed to them by the cops
then they'll know yeah but
it's a [ __ ] it's a good telling of the
story and
uh it really doesn't get into ramirez
himself that much
the uh it's just mostly the
investigation yeah it's not like a
biography of him which i think is good
yeah they just show films of him from
the time
and some of the [ __ ] that he said in the
courtrooms they really didn't go into
what his motives were
you know i think just very very briefly
very superficially
but they didn't go into the whole
[ __ ] night stalker [ __ ]
story you know and the devil and [ __ ]
they didn't really
because they didn't want it that dude
was full of [ __ ]
he was just a rapist he was the edge
lord yeah yeah he was that's like the
worst kind of edge lord was like ooh i
want to be super scary so i'm like look
i'm
yeah the devil is telling me what to do
i'm like man [ __ ] off with that [ __ ]
he was a weak man he was yeah he's a
weak man he was
looking you know i don't know about 5 11
and the dude probably weighed about 125
pounds
i said on the other show it would be
like fighting a kite yeah
you know what i mean he creeped in shot
the man he would shoot the men in the
head at point blank with 22
automatic pistol you know which
not very powerful but it's quiet and uh
and then he'd shoot the women or capture
the women you know if anybody gave him
any problem and then he'd go after the
kids if there were kids in the house
he was a [ __ ] bag yeah he was just a
complete [ __ ] dirt bag and
and as i said he didn't even really have
much of an mo like he would
he didn't do things the same way it's
like a lot of times like you said he
would kidnap a kid
and take him someplace and you know
repeatedly sexually assault them and
then just let them go
um he would break into people's houses
old people
young people he didn't really give a
[ __ ] dude didn't bathe smelled like a
[ __ ] goat
yeah they said one librarian that was
talking about him and said that he'd
come and
he didn't know you know obviously who it
was then but he knew later on and he
said yeah he stinked out
he smelled like a goat and you know
what's funny is that
um you know it's like famously how
disgusting his [ __ ] teeth
are yeah so they knew how disgusting his
teeth were
so they because that was something that
a lot of the survivors had said like he
had the grossest ass teeth like a lot of
them were missing
so they presumed they somehow found out
um
like where his dentist was right because
he had like a dentist in chinatown i
can't remember i think they just found
um
like a business card for that dentist
and they presume since he had shitty
teeth that
it's like okay well this is where this
dude is so they staked out this [ __ ]
dental office
and then there was some kind of
inter-departmental
crap where like one of the departments
was like oh you guys don't have to have
your officers sitting in this dentist
office every day
we'll put an alarm there um so that if
he comes in the doctor can hit the alarm
going hey he's here right now and then
the cops can like run and get him
so um salerno and the other guy were
kind of like um
okay we don't really want to do that but
whatever and so they put the
alarm bell in there and then
you know the day after the cops left
because they had cops
physically sitting in there every single
day in the dentist's office waiting for
this dude to come back
and then so the last day they they leave
you know richard ramirez hasn't been
back the day
after they left richard ramirez came in
and the doctor kept pushing the alarm
but the alarm didn't work
damn so they could have got him like all
the way back then and it was like really
sad and finally like the doctor called
uh the investigators and was like why
didn't you guys come it's like he was in
here today and
he's like i kept pushing the alarm
button and like nothing happened
and it was just like that was like so so
shitty and but there's
there's a couple things about this case
though i mean how many people that he
had he ended up
they don't even know how many he killed
because i think there were some in the
2000s that they found out that he did
later
like murdering a little girl and [ __ ]
like that i think he was he was
convicted of 13
murders five attempted murder 11
rapes and 14 burglary charges because he
would like come in and
you know ransack your [ __ ] house too
like yeah and we
i think we talked about last night a
little bit like that one couple that
the dude got shot in the head and then
he didn't die and then like he chased
[ __ ] ramirez out the [ __ ] door
yeah ramirez shot one dude in the
[ __ ] head with a 25
little 25 auto that [ __ ] bullet
[ __ ] bounced off his skull like that
because if the angle is wrong 25 will
just bounce off it's round
it's a little round a bullet doesn't
weigh much it's not moving very fast and
they're shooting it out of a real
usually shot of a real short
barreled super sub compact pistol
you know it's not known for penetration
not known for being particularly deadly
he shot the dude and [ __ ] bounced off
the corner of his skull and that dude
[ __ ] came
ran right at him he's like oh no you
don't yeah and and
like in ramirez panicked and ran uh he
tried to catch him
he made it out though didn't he yeah
yeah he made it out i don't think i ever
got a hold of him
no um but like i said the dude didn't
weigh
anything you know what i mean there was
physically there's nothing to him he
just
was tall and had a [ __ ] scary looking
face he looked like the devil
that's why he thought he was of the
devil he looked like the devil
plus he i his upbringing they didn't go
a lot
into it on the show um i kind of know
about it because we did a show about him
but he had a real [ __ ] up childhood
like i said not excusing it because a
lot of people did and they turned out
just fine
but he didn't really have a childhood
where
i mean he was just like constantly
beaten he you know his cousin like shot
his
wife in front of him and was like hey
look how awesome that that is and [ __ ]
like that
and showed him all the people he killed
and beheaded in vietnam and all this
other kind of [ __ ] when he was little
so he had a real [ __ ] up and he just
seemed like
even when you see pictures of him he it
looks like there's nothing in there
you know what i mean he just looks like
i think it was partially genetic too
yeah oh i'm sure it was the [ __ ] that he
went through in a kid wasn't it wasn't
enough
to do that no that's what i'm saying
because you know some people you know
lots of people have [ __ ] up childhood
childhoods and don't turn out to be
cereal because there has to be something
else
it wasn't anything to him so that's the
route that he took if he asked me
yeah he wouldn't have had an identity
otherwise yeah one that he would have
earned
he didn't really have any skills or
anything no there was really nothing to
him so
yeah he was just like a discussion he
decided he was going to be the devil
yeah he was just getting with the devil
and i think you see dc yeah and i think
he thought
yeah he thought he was like being cool
it's like oh i'm like a satanist and
blah blah and um i think we talked about
i think one of the best things about the
story was that
he i guess he didn't know that they knew
who he was because he had been arrested
for something else
i think it was like grand theft auto or
some [ __ ] like that so
they had um a mug shot of him
when they found out that this is the
dude that it probably was so they
published the
mug shot in the paper and i guess
richard ramirez didn't know
and he goes to like a [ __ ] what was
it a convenience store or something like
that and then sees his ugly ass face all
over the newspapers
and starts flipping out and then he runs
out and gets on a bus and like people on
the bus like [ __ ] recognize him
and were like that's him and then like
[ __ ] it you know what i mean and then
like people chase
people chased him down the [ __ ]
street and started beating the absolute
[ __ ] out of him with like a tire iron or
pipe or something like that
and they were just like just wailing on
him and i'm just like i kind of feel
like
maybe maybe safety i kind of feel like
the cops should have just been like
yeah back in the way yeah it's just
because they just they would have torn
that dude to pieces if the
cops hadn't come he ran to the cops for
safety from if i remember correctly
i think he did yeah like he raised some
accounts they're hitting me
[Laughter]
you know that's that's always the way
isn't it those [ __ ] type of people
they're just like now they're the
victims suddenly
but it's like i mean this [ __ ] like
i said
i mean one of the worst things i don't
even think i remember
knowing this detail before but one of
his early early crimes
i think he raped and killed the woman
and then
he cut her eyeballs out yeah and put
them
in her jewelry box and took the jewelry
box with him so he could like keep her
eyeballs
yeah like what the [ __ ] yeah he thought
he was doing some devil [ __ ]
yeah it's like he's full of [ __ ] he's so
gross and they ever talk about did they
ever find out where he lived
yeah they had to have huh yeah yeah yeah
they found his uh
witnesses said he lived in filth yeah
why that is not surprising is it yeah
his apartment was just he looked like
he just stunk i mean and everybody and a
lot of people said that too like i said
that librarian that said that he would
come in there like said he just smelled
like a goat you could smell him from
like a long time away
[ __ ] up rotten ass teeth it was [ __ ]
up right now's teeth yeah he had [ __ ]
meth mouth big time i don't know what
his [ __ ] problem was
but um somebody said he only ate junk
food yeah maybe that's what it was
now i will say that um
there are a lot of this shouldn't be a
problem for people that follow true
crime but there are a lot of
photographs of the crime scenes in this
like not i don't know they usually show
like kind of partial
ones they don't show like really really
really
really bad ones but
and usually they kind of blur the faces
out or like put like a little bit like a
black
box over the face you know what i mean
like just out of respect for the victims
i guess but it's some of the crime scene
photos are
pretty gross and pretty upsetting so
i'm just saying and like i said i don't
think i've just because it's just
because i've seen like a few reviews
that said ah man it's like i really wish
they wouldn't have shown some of those
pictures because they were like really
i didn't think they were that graphic i
i didn't think they were either but the
idea what
what happened you know kind of what the
scene looked like
uh some of the [ __ ] was pretty bloody
you know i mean he was bashing people in
the head with [ __ ]
shooting people in the head there'd be
blood everywhere
but it's not anything our audience
couldn't handle i mean it's hit you know
yeah i wasn't that great i mean
obviously i'm bothered by it because
it's real people but
it you know i've seen like a lot worse
um
but i don't you know i'm just saying
that
they and i thought it was interesting
too that they had a lot of interviews
with people because remember that that
one couple
that they were she was like sitting on
the couch or something and her husband
was like in bed or whatever and she
heard somebody like at the window or
like opening the window
and then she thought it was her husband
and like sat up and was like hey
whatever
the husband's name was and then i guess
whoever was outside like ran away and
then when the cops came
they found that same shoe print outside
of their [ __ ] window
yeah and it's like it's a good thing
that she just sat up and yelled because
that made him run away he would have
busted in and killed him
no she made the husband go check yeah
yeah she made the husband go check he
went out there and he [ __ ] ran away
but um they got his footprint and proved
it
cop put a damn thing over the footprint
wasn't it where they put the box over
the footprint
yeah the same case well they got because
that house like the guy that lived there
was a cop
yeah okay you know he was off duty
obviously but because he was home he was
like sleeping yeah
but um yeah so he knew yeah you know
when he saw
the [ __ ] under the window serena shut up
go shut him says oh man you're lucky
this dude getting your house this is a
bad dude
yeah because nobody knew who it was like
i said it wasn't really common knowledge
at the time that this was the same
person like doing all this stuff because
not only were the crimes a lot of the
crimes like vastly different like people
didn't know like all the child
abductions and then all the killings and
robberies and stuff and rapes were the
same person because it was just all
these different kind of crimes
but he also committed crimes in a bunch
of different areas like
he did like mostly in and around l.a but
then he did some in san francisco
also and um at one point too
like this again i like that they kind of
focused
the main focus is frank salerno and uh
gil carrillo
yeah um and they're talking about how
they figured certain [ __ ]
out and also talking about how the case
like affected them like affected their
lives and affected their families
because at one point
ramirez killed somebody i can't remember
if it's just one person or two
people like only a five-minute
drive away from korea's house and hit so
his wife and kids
had to go someplace else yeah you know
what i mean like into hiding because
they were afraid
they were like you know they said it's
really really hard to
fathom how terrified everybody was
in l.a just because you know it wasn't
like you say oh he only goes after
prostitutes or really
he always went after anybody it was
anybody and he could have been anywhere
this would make a really good movie i'm
sure they've made movies about it
yeah because the story sounds like a
movie script and
um you could write it around carino his
name korea right korea
yeah right around korea as the young cop
who
kind of gets in with salerno you know
what i mean [ __ ]
and he's on this big case and trying to
solve it and he's stressing out because
his family's at home he can't watch his
family he's chasing the
he's chasing the [ __ ] night stalker
and the night stall and his family's in
the night stalkers territory
and so he it and you know he's getting
all these sleepless nights big case and
finally cracks the case
it's just a it's a good story and the
way that they
yeah the way they make really good
movies with this the way they kind of
solved it i think they made i'm
pretty sure they made a movie called
night stalker when was it 2012 i want to
say
but i haven't seen it yeah um i feel
like david fincher needs to make
this you know what i mean it almost
sounds like fiction but it isn't
yeah you know what i mean i mean you
could you could tell the plot accurately
and it would seem like a cop movie
yeah you know what i mean yeah but
that's how it really happened but i was
i mean
and here's something else people as they
get understand that a case like this is
a once-in-a-lifetime case for a cop most
cops don't
don't get a case like this it's once in
a lifetime salerno had two
he had two in a lot of yeah because he
did hillside stranglers right but most
for the most for the average detective
they don't get
this is like once in a lifetime case so
well thankfully
so getting on the case though is a huge
like uh
it's like a it's like a huge boost into
your into your [ __ ] reputation if you
solve it
if you're on the case that if you
cracked it yeah because you know your
career [ __ ]
will blow up yeah and um
because everybody was saying everybody
was just so [ __ ] relieved to get this
yeah
you know jack wagon off the phone even
though they didn't catch him but they
were going they did catch him in a
certain way because they
figured out who he was well they figured
out who he was putting his face in the
paper
got him caught got him caught yeah
because and so the kind of the
kind of the the the [ __ ] neighborhood
got credit for the arrest
you know yeah because immediately they
had huge parties afterwards and
you know yeah when they were taking well
because everyone was so relieved they
were [ __ ] terrified
of this dude because they didn't know
who he was they didn't know what he
looked like there were a couple of
drawings of him but it's like you never
knew where he was gonna turn up it's
like you know what i mean [ __ ]
terrifying yeah it was kind of like a
scene where the [ __ ] local community
and the cops were bonding over the
catching the dude together it was kind
of like the end of
return of the jedi with the [ __ ] nub
[Laughter]
that's what they were doing
that was a weird association i get what
you're saying
the
[Laughter]
fireworks and [ __ ] that's so [ __ ]
funny but yeah
so yeah if you're really at a true crime
you really gotta watch this i mean it's
um
it's just there was a lot of i knew a
lot about the case but i'm really really
glad that they
kind of went a lot more into victims
people that
um you know people that survived people
that kind of had close calls
and you know talked about the cops and
how it affected the cops and how it
affected the community i kind of wish
the only thing i wish they would have
gone a little bit more
into um just the [ __ ]
god that interdepartmental kind of [ __ ]
where it's like oh they want to
share information with the other police
departments and all this other kind of
crap because i feel like that's a big
thing
that happens in a lot of these big cases
you know especially serial killers that
kill in different jurisdictions and it's
almost kind of like they're just being
petty little [ __ ] being like no we
don't want to share information with you
because we want to get all the credit
and blah blah blah
and then it's and meanwhile people are
getting [ __ ] murdered just for your
stupid [ __ ] what they do
you know what i mean so i was just like
i really wish they'd gone a little bit
more into that but it but
like i said the focus of it was really
on the cops and the investigation
and you know the [ __ ] about the shoe
print and the [ __ ] about the dennis
office and all that kind of stuff so
which i
really find interesting i like all that
kind of forensic
investigation stuff and i'm glad that
they kind of downplayed
although we did talk about on the show a
little bit last night that after he got
caught
and of course he turned the courtroom
into like look how awesome i am i'm like
a [ __ ] rock star
and then like all of these he would have
like [ __ ] groupies and stuff like
turning up in the [ __ ]
courtroom with all the [ __ ] victims
families there and [ __ ] like that
and like this woman you know her grandma
got killed for [ __ ] sake
and um so she's she's like i had to
leave the courtroom for a little while
and she's like can i go out there and
sit on the bench
and there's like a dude sitting next to
me that had like a pentagram honestly he
was one of his fanboys and she was just
like [ __ ] me and it was like really
horrible
and then um and then afterwards like all
those [ __ ] women
that sent like just way too many women
like sending him
naked pictures of themselves didn't he
end up marrying one of those [ __ ]
groupies or some [ __ ] like that
what if he got in some new teeth when he
was in prison
i hope not so i don't think taxpayers
should have to pay for that [ __ ]
pull all his teeth out and give him
dentures yeah
that'd probably be the only thing to do
because the ones he had left were just
so [ __ ]
nasty yeah i lost all those teeth he's
just a disgusting disgusting
[ __ ]
but yeah all right so prison is probably
the cleanest he ever was
well yeah now that you've been now that
you put it that way like a big
big move up because i feel like the
other prisoners aren't going to let you
walk around smelling like ass crack all
[ __ ] day long
they probably would have kept him in
some kind of a maximum security cell
where he couldn't interact with other
people too much
yeah probably what they would have done
i don't know if they would have him in
general
general population you have to go back
and check no because they said that they
put him in a special set well that was
at the central lockup yeah yeah yeah
they had a minute
in the same cell where they had bianca
bianchi yeah
and he was the hillside striker and he
was like oh it's the famous dude itself
i'm a big fan of his work yeah yeah yeah
[ __ ] serial killers man that's the
[ __ ] grossest yeah
like cess was like how does a rotten two
stinking serial killer get a bunch of
groupies see that's what i'd like to
know
the [ __ ] the matter with you ladies
and i i was watching like another review
of this and somebody had i don't think
this was in the documentary but there
was actually a clip
from uh from his trial and there was
this goth chick
who kind of looked like um he looked
like um
what's-her-face wouldn't a writer from
beetlejuice or whatever and she had come
to see him and she would had written him
letters and all this other kind of stuff
and the reporter was like
you know he's like a serial killer and
has killed like a whole bunch of people
and she's just like yeah
and i was just like oh my god you need
to be punched
all those women need to be punched i
don't get it but yeah
so uh yeah so it's it's good if you're
into true crime if you're
you want to know more about the night
stalker you want to know more about the
investigation because like i said it's
more
about that than about him which i liked
um then it's on netflix it's
three and a half four hours time
commitment
and it's worth it um is that all we have
to say about it all right
so we will be back again tomorrow
talking about another movie
i got a new one i gotta watch tonight
and i have another one that i watched
the other day that i will probably
review on
tuesday so we will talk to you guys
again tomorrow
have a good rest of your weekend